what do you think was the number one
contributing factor to things ending up
the way it is now
do you think would you accredit that to
feminism
modern feminism for me is very different
from the way feminism was intended to be
you know so i'm somebody that yes you
know people who were initially
advocating for women's suffrage and who
were advocating for
women to have equal opportunity in
education what about great abortion
well i'm pro-life so you know from my
perspective that's a problem in many
respects um
and i feel like it's been glorified and
it's been like oh you know you can just
sleep around and i see all the videos on
tick tock now everyone's like oh if you
you know make it harder for people to
get abortion i'm gonna not be able to
you know sleep around so guys who want
us to sleep around you should be against
this too and i'm like wow this is
societal decay yeah but that's what
that's that but that also kind of
demonstrates the power that women have
over men that's right that's it and and
when we talk about the power dynamics
between men and women a lot of people
don't understand that women have a lot
of power a lot more power than we would
like to give them what do you mean by
that well i mean that people will say
that a housewife is weak but my wife
gets to sleep until 2 p.m while i'm up
at 6 a.m making videos so who's really
the boss
you know what i mean like
i still get the final say in my
relationship sure because she trusts my
judgment because my judgment gives
results and it shows results and it's
gotten us to the place that we we are
now so when it comes to making the final
decision she'll give me that ability
people will say that means that you're
the boss you're controlling but like i
said she's sleeping until 2 pm if she
wants and i'm up in the morning making
videos
see i thought you were going to go at it
with the angle of you know if
women oftentimes complain about you know
men oh men sleep around they well you
know what they sleep around with someone
right so the way that you stop that
behavior is that you stop putting out so
easily you you command respect and as a
result men will have to change the way
they behave but that's why i believe
that majority of the consequences that
we see today are due to feminism
i believe that women weren't playing
fair and then men just said okay
whatever you got 30 of men that are not
sleeping with anyone and you know
they're they're in a situation now where
they're like what the the thing about
that because when i say that a lot of
people assume that that's just a problem
for men
not really understanding that that's 30
of me like a family is a man's
a family is what holds a man to society
a man has no reason to care about
anything that goes on in society unless
he has a family because men just tend to
be more independent so if you want a man
to
like care about society give him a
family give him a reason to get up and
be productive or you won't and that's
what you're seeing with a lot of guys a
lot of guys don't care to be productive
because they don't see themselves having
a family so you're saying that feminism
caused that how connect those dots for
me well because feminism in it
it incentivizes women to
sleep with the top men
so that's going to skew it so that the
only men that are actually getting play
are the men that are hyper successful
and you see that and really it comes
from women having an inflated ego it's
an inflated ego because when you
introduce social media and you have a
woman that used to have to put on a
dress and have a good attitude and be
friendly to everybody uh getting uh
to get kind of attention getting
attention for just posting a booty
picture the same amount of attention
and then they wake up to 20 messages a
day saying you're beautiful and perfect
for absolutely doing nothing you start
to believe that you're a 10. and if an
average woman starts to believe that
she's a 10 she believes that she's
better than the average man and that's
what you're seeing a lot of why can't
guys just discern them though why can't
they just see that for what it is and
not give it the attention because
there's also the angle of like okay you
got a bunch you can see it a mile away
you know you got the attention seekers
out there you know all the images are
filtered you don't even know what's
going on those are often the women i
always say that you go to bed one night
with some when you wake up the next
morning you're like who is that they
look completely different it's like the
makeups off everything i saw those of
those videos last night about like women
transforming with without you know the
fake eyelashes and that's okay it's a
whole other thing yeah you instagram
men just say to themselves you know what
i'm not going to give this time
if you want like a real woman and i use
that term i know i get heat in the
atmosphere for saying that sometimes but
if you want a real woman by that meaning
someone who has self-respect who someone
is going to respect you
why not just stop giving attention to
that and give it to women out there who
are playing or playing the game right
the problem is men are hardwired for
sexual opportunity so when there's a
woman that presents herself is easier
for sexual opportunity men are going to
indulge regardless of if they want to or
not like i always say and women will say
and i agree that men like you said
should practice more discipline but you
know if if you take a woman women can
bench 135 pounds but it would take a lot
more discipline to do it than a man men
can be sexually disciplined but it takes
a lot more discipline to do it than a
woman because they're naturally designed
to be more selective when it comes to
sex so the problem is you have a lot of
women putting themselves out there and
then men are taking the bait so much so
that you ain't even got to give out as a
woman anymore there are there are men
forking money away for women in bikini
pictures on only fans you know what i'm
saying so i just think that the problem
is the promiscuity and the promiscuity
comes from the sexual revolution of
feminism and also we believe that
potentially also just women delaying
that time period of when they ultimately
settle down so you know that's also
because of feminism right if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]